[музика]
скажи чесно Як ти
тримаєшся зараз така відповідь для мене
актуальна
тому що в тебе є відповідальність за
твою сім'ю за твоїх дітей в тебе є
робота яку треба робити
ми виживаємо і ми зобов'язані це пройти
і ми точно виживемо
[музика]
зосередь увагу на ногах
підніми одну з них і зроби активний рух
так ніби ти пробуєш струсити щось з себе
ну неначе песики обтрушуються щойно
вилічи з води при цьому Спробуй
максимально розслабити ногу якою ти
робиш рухи потім зробити саме іншою далі
справа за руками
Виконай вправу кілька разів чергуючи
напрям і уявляє що разом із рухами ти
поступово струшуєш із себе увесь Негатив
який ти накопичив
додай цю техніку в свою аптечку
самодопомоги більше тут